- Hello, and welcome to
Ed talks with con academy.
I'm Kristen DiCerbo, the
Chief Learning Officer
at Khan Academy.
And I am excited today
to talk to Mike Flanagan,
the CEO of the Mastery
Transcript Consortium.
We'll find out what that
is and what it means
for mastery learning, to have
such a such an organization.
Before we get started,
Khan Academy is a nonprofit organization,
and we do rely on donors like you,
to help us keep doing the work we do.
If you go to khanacademy.org/donate,
you will find a place where
you can make a contribution
to help us keep doing the
work that we're doing.
Second, we do wanna thank
some of our supporters,
who have helped us with the
COVID-19 crisis response,
including AT&T, General
Motors, and Fastly.
Next, if you want to listen
to other conversations
that I've had, or that Sal has
had with interesting guests,
you can find us where
you get your podcasts,
at Homeroom with Sal Podcast.
So you can tune in and listen.
And with that, I am excited to welcome,
Mike Flanagan, welcome.
- Greetings, delighted to be here.
- Excellent. So I will
start from the beginning.
You're the CEO and Mastery
Transcript Consortium.
I bet, when you were a kid,
that wasn't quite what
you said you wanted to be
when you grew up.
What is your career trajectory
been like to bring you here?
- Yeah, that's true.
It would be a really interesting,
toddler walking around being like,
"I wanna lead a nonprofit
association of schools."
Yeah, so I started my career
as an English teacher.
I taught at an independent
school in Honolulu, Hawaii,
and I taught there for three years.
And it was about as cool as it sounds.
It was really great.
And I moved from teaching into starting
on the path of academia.
And then I did a pivot, and
I wound up in technology.
And I actually wound up doing
a bunch of startup companies,
both with some college classmates,
college classmate of mine, and
other friends along the way.
And then things came full circle
where I've now wound up in this role.
That is a really interesting
hybrid of teaching
and pedagogy, and schools, and technology.
And yeah, it wasn't a linear path,
but it it's one that landed me here.
And I'm pretty excited about it.
And I think that idea of non-linear paths
is actually probably a pretty good fit
for a lot of the things we think about,
in terms of our schools and
the way we try and serve kids.
- That totally makes
sense. And I always say,
my career path, I can tell
the story looking backwards,
it makes sense.
- Yeah.
- But at any given point,
it seems like I was making some left turns
or some weird shifts, yeah. (laughs)
So it's also teacher
appreciation week this week.
So before we get started
talking about your work,
are there any teachers that
you'd like to recognize
from your past?
- Yeah, I grew up and
I was in high school.
I loved school, right?
It was my happy place.
But I was very much a STEM kid.
And so my high school science teacher,
Mr. Ezekiel, who taught me AP Chemistry
and gave me, probably, started
me on the road to teaching.
When it was time for us
to get ready for the AP,
he broke the textbook in different chunks,
and had each of us, kind
of give us responsibility
to teach one.
And he gave me Organic Chemistry,
and the light bulb went on.
- Woo!
- I realized like, oh, I loved,
I was so much more comfortable, confident,
that I really had owned the material,
'cause I had to explain
it to somebody else.
That sense of how do
you step outta yourself,
and really figure out how
do I make this make sense
to other people.
The light bulb really went on for me,
in a lot of different ways.
So Mr. Ezekiel, if you're
out there, thank you.
- Awesome. Excellent.
So let's talk Mastery
Transcript Consortium,
what is that?
Tell us what it is and what you do.
- Yeah, so we're a nonprofit.
And what we really are is a collection
of innovative schools.
We've got a network of just
about 400 high schools,
mostly here in the US, some international.
And what our schools have in common
is the concept of mastery learning.
And we will unpack mastery
learning, I'm sure,
throughout this discussion.
What it is, and what means?
But really at its core,
it's an embrace of real
learner centered pedagogy,
and a rethinking of assessment.
That's really centered on the idea,
which shouldn't be
radical, but kind of is,
that all children are
capable of learning, right?
And it's our job as school
leaders and system leaders
to create structures and supports,
to make sure that they're
all doing the work,
and really mastering this material
at the highest level.
What happens, and this is
where things get interesting,
this is where the transcript comes in,
and also the consortium,
is that if you lead a
really innovative school,
and you are adopting a
whole bunch of the models
that we'll talk about,
throughout this discussion,
you're gonna basically stop
producing a lot of the metrics,
that we think of, as high school.
So if you're giving credit
based on mastery, proficiency,
it's a really important
tenant of mastery learning.
The basic idea is, hey, don't give credit
based on the number of hours
students have been exposed
to a subject, give them credit
when they've actually nailed it.
Some students will do it more quickly,
some will need more time.
But once you do that,
you're not giving credit
based on the Carnegie Unit anymore.
You're not giving credit
based on credit hours.
When you think about the
way we assess students,
it's just normal, traditional grading.
Assumes that kids will be
distributed on a curve.
Some kids are good at
school, some kids are not.
Mastery learning rejects that principle.
We basically say, "No, all
kids are capable of learning."
Some will learn faster than
others, and that's fine,
but they can all be really proficient,
and some will even be advanced.
And in that kind of model, what is a C-?
A C- doesn't even exist
anymore, in those models.
So you take those two
things, credit hours,
traditional grades, you put
those in the parking lot,
And then you also take this
idea of like, what is school?
What should kids be learning?
And traditional transcripts
really think about
classic academic subjects,
English, Math, Science, Social Studies.
There's nothing wrong with
those things, they're great.
But there's a lot more
that we want kids to learn
and be excellent at.
Particularly, if we're gonna prepare them
for a really interesting,
and maybe volatile and uncertain future.
We wanna give 'em 21st century skills.
We want 'em have opportunities
to do deep interdisciplinary learning.
There's literally no place
to capture those kinds of
21st century competencies
in a traditional transcript.
So what you have is this
really odd phenomenon,
where schools that are in some ways,
being the best possible school.
That brain science says you can design,
is now producing kids with student records
that don't make any sense to college.
Because college is used to
thinking about credits, grades,
and the classic academic disciplines.
That's a big issue.
I'm, as a parent, as an educator,
I think these schools are awesome.
I want as many of them as possible to grow
and propagate around the country.
I want every kid to be
able to have access to one.
If the message is,
"Oh, you can go to this
really innovative school,
but you might not get into college
'cause you look different,"
that's not gonna be good for adoption.
So college is not the only,
or even the most important destination,
but it's definitely a blocking issue.
if we cannot show that
these innovative schools
can still give kids access
to higher ed campuses,
that's gonna be bad for us
as system change agents.
And so that's what the
transcript is designed to do.
It's a translation tool
that takes the models
that our schools have, and
through our best effort,
presents them to higher ed
in a way that's interactive,
usable, and hopefully
makes a lot of sense,
and helps 'em understand where
these K12 schools are headed.
- Got it.
That makes sense.
So to unpack some of that,
let's start with the pedagogy
and the mastery learning piece.
So part of the reason
I wanted to talk to you
is because Khan Academy also
really believes in that idea
of it's it's okay to
fail your first attempt.
It's not about what score
you get on one attempt,
it's about reaching a high
level of proficiency on a skill
and how you get there.
What are some of the things
that you see as foundational
for mastery learning and
some of the key tenants?
- Yeah.
Well, I mean there's foundational,
and then there's also, what
becomes possible, right?
- Yeah.
- So foundational is
definitely this idea of
students progress when they've
mastered a particular skill,
and not before.
And if you're going to do that,
that necessitates a more
personalized approach, right?
You can't have kids
learning at different rates,
and then expect them
all to move in lockstep.
They're just fundamentally,
it doesn't doesn't compute.
So that has implications
for your school day,
your school schedule.
It implies certain kinds of technologies
to reduce the administrative burden
on school leaders and faculty.
But at the end of the day,
personalized approach is really key.
Thinking about those cross-disciplinary
21st century competencies and skills,
finding ways of re-entering
those into what kids do,
and helping them understand
that a lot of things
that used to be tacit in school, right?
What does it mean to be a good leader?
What does it mean
to really collaborate
effectively on a team?
What does it mean to be creative,
or to solve problems creatively?
Those aren't like intangible things.
They can be taught.
You can describe to a pretty
high level of precision.
What good performance
looks like in those things?
And if you start a process of
exposing kids to those things,
as early as eighth, ninth grade,
there's no reason why they all can't get
to really high levels of performance
by the time they leave high school.
As opposed to sort of focusing
on your academic subjects
and hoping they pick up
that stuff along the way.
So those two things,
21st century skills that
are cross-disciplinary,
credit based on
proficiency, not seat time,
those are the essentials.
And then what becomes possible
is a lot of opportunities
to have kids in engage in deeper,
more purpose-driven learning.
So if you have students,
if they're given more choice, right?
'Cause they're on a more
personalized approach,
and they're not wedded to
studying the same things
as all their classmates at the same times,
then there's no reason
they can't do more project-based learning.
Do long form capstones
or independent studies.
You'll hear me use the word,
we, a lot in these discussions
because we've got this amazing
network of schools, right?
And they're private schools,
public schools, districts,
there's rural, urban, big, small,
it's amazing heterogeneous
group, and that's a good thing.
But a lot of them have kids doing project
and problem-based learning.
Either individually or in teams,
they're having kids solve
real world problems.
Not like cookbook science,
like you would do in lab,
where it's like, oh, we're gonna measure,
drop something and see
how long it takes to fall.
Well, surprise, gravity's constant.
We know how long it's gonna take to fall.
We're gonna have 'em solve
messy problems, right?
There's a reason a lot of
our schools embrace things
like design thinking and entrepreneurship.
It's not just 'cause they're hip,
it's because they're cyclical.
They assume a certain amount of iteration,
like try, test, iterate, repeat, adjust.
Those things, we think are really powerful
because they create that space to fail
in a constructive environment, right?
To that, it's okay not to be right.
Your first attempt is not
always gonna be your best one.
So those are, I think, are
that combination of things
that are essential to mastery learning
and things that become
possible and pretty exciting.
And frankly, more
interesting for students.
We talk a lot about the mission
of Mastery Transcript Schools.
Well, really all schools I think,
is to prepare young adults
for what they want to do next.
Whether it's college, whether it's career,
whether it's kind of something in between.
What I think is really
interesting is that for many kids
in traditional schools,
the hardest word in that sentence is want.
what do you want to do next?
We don't ask kids what
they want to do very often,
in traditional schools,
we tell them what to do.
And as a result, they
internalize this message
that to be a student, to be a learner,
is to show up and do what you're told.
And then we launch them into the world,
hopefully, we want them to be successful,
and it turns out that's not
the way the world works.
You have to figure out what
you're gonna do, specifically.
So yeah.
- Yeah.
- That's like the opening...
- It feels like one of
those 21st century skills
is actually learning how to learn,
and being an owner of
your own learning and...
- Yeah.
- Knowing how to set goals for yourself,
and see, monitor if you're on track.
- Yeah.
- And doing all of those things,
to understand how to learn.
- Yeah. I think we started,
like phase one of MTC
was very much focused on showing
that kids could get into college
without these traditional metrics, right?
And one of the reasons we've
been really successful,
even with a small number of schools
that have fully adopted our transcript.
We've gotten kids into 250
colleges and universities,
some of the most selective
and also open enrollment,
two year technical programs,
everything in between.
But I'm always really
quick to tell people,
it's not actually because
of the transcript.
The transcript does not
give you an advantage
in getting into MIT or to Caltech.
But going to a mastery
learning-based school,
like one in which you're
encouraged throughout four years
to really do deep work, to think about it,
reflect on that work with
an adult in your life.
Maybe write something about it,
maybe present it to a group,
and then make a decision about
what you wanna do next with that.
Maybe it's iterate.
Maybe it's revise it.
Maybe it's go a different
direction, try something new.
If you do that cycle really purposefully,
and with a lot of feedback in coaching,
by the time you get out the other end,
your metacognitive skills,
what you just said, Kris,
learning how to learn, they
are absolutely super powered.
And so when you talk
to our kids, our kids,
the kids that go to these schools,
they just make amazing applicants,
whether they're applying
for an internship or a job,
or applying to college.
Because they've got
real, authentic answers
to some of these essential questions.
What do you want to do?
If we give you a slot
at this campus, right?
Where you could do any sort of things,
major in all kinds of different subjects,
and study with some of
the world's best experts,
what are you gonna do here?
What will you do to take advantage of it?
If we give you an
internship at our company,
how can you contribute?
What are some things that are interesting?
Why do you wanna work here
versus somewhere else?
They have those answers
because it's not the first
time they've been asked
those kinds of really deep questions
about what they're doing and why.
And that for us, is
that metacognitive move,
learning how to learn that you described.
- Yeah. Yeah, absolutely.
So let's paint a picture then,
if you don't have take
a test, get a grade,
what does it look like
to be able to demonstrate
that you have have these skills?
- Yeah, I mean, I think,
our schools still have tests, right?
Like I don't want to
paint a utopian picture
where our kids like never look at anything
that looks like an exam.
You still need like academic content,
and there's a place for that.
But I do think that what you'll see,
and much more often is
much less focused on
high stakes as assessment,
and much more judicious use of that,
and much more focus on
feedback, right, on.
So what we wanna do is have students
really engaged in real work,
and then have them giving
feedback to one another,
teaching them how to give
feedback in a constructive way.
That's a pretty important skill.
It's a life skill.
I think we've all, unfortunately,
had experiences where
we've worked with people,
who maybe didn't have that skill,
didn't know how to give
constructive feedback.
And that's not like a recipe
for like awesome performance.
So helping kids get real
feedback, both from one another,
and from adults.
And then creating really clear structures
for what they're being assessed against.
So I think one of the things
that every single one of our schools.
In fact, I would say, you can't
use the mastery transcript,
or really any competency based transcript,
unless you as a school, as
a learning organization,
have a really, really good
portrait of a graduate, right?
And so portrait of a graduate
for us is the term of art
for a really well designed
set of competencies.
And ideally, what they've been created
in a backwards design process, right?
You ask yourself the essential question of
what do we want our kids to be able to do
by the time they leave our campus, right?
What do we want 'em to be able to do
by the time they cross the
stage and grab that diploma.
And so for us, that portrait of a graduate
is really the cornerstone to that,
because every single one of
those competencies, in turn,
should have really clear descriptions.
Like with a lot of
Blooms Taxonomy language,
about what those demonstrated
behaviors look like.
One of the real challenges
of traditional grading
is that sometimes students
don't actually really know
what they're being graded on.
And so I think one of the advantages
of so-called standard
space grading, right?
And if you look at the work
that Jill Feldman has done
in Grading for Equity,
it's this idea that,
oh, these things have
to be super explicit.
Everyone should know on day
one, what good looks like?
And when you see it spelled
out that way you realize
how often that isn't true, sometimes,
in traditional grading environments.
The other thing is that you
should really be assessing
what it is essential to
the school environment,
like the learning, as opposed to things
like behavior and compliance.
There's a lot of like
traditional grading models
that blur the line between
classroom management,
and actually measuring
what kids can actually do,
and what they're actually learning.
And it's really important to stay,
we think, really squarely
on one side or the other.
And then lastly, I think,
so standards based grading is great,
but it is the beginning of
a school evolution process.
True mastery learning is,
if you think about it as a Venn Diagram,
standards-based grading
is a smaller circle,
and mastery-based assessment
is in a larger circle,
around it.
- Got it.
That makes sense.
So lots of questions,
but we do have a question
coming in asking about,
for the average teacher,
who's maybe in a traditional school,
but wants to begin doing some of this.
How can they bring some of these ideas
into their current practice,
when maybe the system isn't quite set up
for the doing it, yet?
- Yeah.
And I think I really appreciate
whoever asked that question
because it it's really
important to take a step back.
And if you say, well, why do we even have,
or why do we even need a
mastery transcript consortium?
Why not just have
teachers start to do this?
It's that the system change
is really hard, right?
We have to change both our
policies in our 50 states.
We have to change the technologies
that our teachers, and administrators,
and learners have access to.
And so one of the reasons
we're a nonprofit,
and trying to drive
system change over time
is because we know that
this is a long road.
There's a lot of work to do.
And we're really glad
to have so many allies
in the space, right?
We're part of a much larger
and really vibrant ecosystem
of nonprofit players
that are all working on
competency-based education
and personalized learning and,
and mastery-based assessment.
And all pulling schools, we
think in a good direction.
That said, if you are a teacher,
and you are out on an island, right?
You're the only person at
your school, theoretically,
who is interested in rethinking
grading and assessment.
There are things you can do.
Contract-based grading is a model
that is most mastery-like, I think.
Given if you have in the confines
of a traditional classroom
and a traditional schedule.
So you don't have autonomy, necessarily,
over how long your class is gonna run,
or maybe even, what
your kids are studying.
What you can do is, on day one,
be really clear with students
about what the standards
are for them to achieve,
say a B or an A.
And then work with them
throughout the year,
to help them understand where they are,
in terms of getting it,
and then giving them space.
And this is a real key principle
of standards-based grading
and grading for equity.
Giving them space to retake and retry,
kind of high stakes assessments,
whether they're big projects, or tests.
And there's a really amazing
array of literature on that.
And MTC does not own that space, right?
If you go to just even on social media,
there are incredible networks
of teachers self organizing,
around teachers going gradeless,
the Ungrading Movement.
There is a real ground swell of educators
who realize, oh, we've gotten
ourselves into a situation
where the thing that is
supposed to measure learning,
which is assessment grading,
has now kind of in a
weird way loop to back,
where it's actually pulling
and pushing against learning.
And I don't think anybody ever designed
and wanted that to be the case.
I think we should all
agree that our assessments
should help kids learn,
not push against them.
And I think there's growing
recognition around that,
and a lot of resources available.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Excellent.
Thank you.
So I know, I'm also on the
board of the Khan Lab School,
whose been one of the
original users of this,
and when I first saw the
transcript itself, I was like,
"Oh, this is amazing."
Can you share with us a little bit about
just what a transcript looks like in MTC?
- Yeah, and so I will just say,
we are very lucky to
have a very simple URL,
it's mastery.org.
So if you want to kind of learn more about
what that transcript looks like,
and see a version of it.
At the core, a mastery
transcript is a visualization
of a school's competency model.
And we spent a lot of time,
before we even built, sketched,
the first transcript system,
we spent a lot of time
talking to higher education.
Our team, we were really lucky.
We were able to sign some
confidentiality agreements
and actually sit in admissions on offices,
and listen as the readers were looking
at actual student folders.
And what you realize is,
that even though the
colleges vary quite a lot,
there's a workflow of
what they're looking for.
The first question they always have is,
what is this school?
What is this program like?
I want to understand the
context of where this applicant
has done their highschool work.
And so traditionally, they
might look at a school profile.
They might then look
back at the transcript,
and might then look,
try, and cross-reference.
So for us, the front page
of the mastery transcript
is a visualization of that
school's competencies.
And by looking at it,
you can instantly tell if
we've done our job right.
What that shape of the school is, right?
Or you can see this is where
they spend the most time.
We're really big believers that students,
learners in mastery-based
schools should develop
what we call like a jagged profile, right?
So if you give kids time
and space to go deep
in things they really care about,
they'll go in different directions.
That's a good thing.
That's a feature, not a bug.
And so schools can have
jagged profiles, as well.
And so we want those to
literally pop off the page.
The second thing you'll look
at then is that jagged profile,
the competencies for the
student, in particular.
If every student who got the
diploma earned these over here,
then individual students will
go in different directions.
And we have a separate
section that visualizes that.
We call them sort of advanced competencies
or advanced mastery credits.
And so in that space is
really where we can start
to help colleges do what
they say they want to do,
which is match their applicants,
based on fit to the programs
they're applying to,
and the campuses that they're applying to.
And so if you have students
who say that they're applying
to a nursing program, right,
you're gonna look for
some STEM background,
but you're also gonna look,
ideally I would think,
for some kind of service orientation.
So that student has started
to do some things that show,
yeah, they really care about other people.
They wanna spend their time,
maybe it's volunteer work,
maybe it's caring for siblings.
But making moves choices in their life
That show that they've got an orientation
towards helping other people out,
that's a pretty big predictor,
whether he or she is gonna be successful
in a nursing environment.
So I think that's really important.
And you can imagine
other examples like that.
so what that fit between
where the student has chosen
to go deep and what they
say they care about,
and what they want to
go deeply in college.
When you see that alignment,
it helps you identify that
in, it clicks really quickly
in ways that honestly
traditional transcripts don't.
One of the strange things
about a traditional schooling model
is that as students get more successful,
quote, unquote in school,
their transcripts actually
start to look really similar.
They're all taking the same
AP classes or honors classes.
They're all getting 4.0 grades.
And so the thing that is most important,
the thing that's supposed to capture,
like four years of high school,
actually doesn't tell you much at all
about what makes them unique or different.
And so that's one of the problems
that we tried to lean into, pretty hard.
- That totally makes sense.
And so what's been the
reaction from the colleges
and universities that have
gotten these transcripts?
- Yeah.
So what I always say are,
our reach has been limited,
but our uptake has been really good.
And here's what I mean.
There were a million distinct applications
that got processed
through the common application
last season, right?
So we have a lot of work in front of us.
If we want 1%...
- Yeah, it's a big number.
- (indistinct) transcripts out there.
And so if you were to go to any,
pick a random folder reader, if you will,
an admissions officer at a campus,
"Hey, have you, have you
seen a mastery transcript?"
Statistically, almost certainly,
they're gonna be like,
"Nope, I have no idea what
you're talking about."
- Right.
- But for the schools that
got a mastery transcript,
we've got a really good
track record of getting
in front of those proactively,
and talking to schools,
college readers about that experience.
And it's pretty obvious, right?
If I call you in the abstract and say,
"Would you like to do a focus group
about this strange
alternative transcript?"
You're like, "No, I don't think so."
But if I call you and I was like,
"Hey, by the way, this is
arriving like in two weeks."
- Right.
- (indistinct) to it.
Or more importantly, would
you like to give us feedback
when you're done?
There, I think we've got a
really good uptake there.
I think it also helps too that
when we started this work,
I think there were a lot
of high school, excuse me,
college readers who, the
concept of competency-based
or master-based education
seemed a little bit abstract.
They're like, "I don't know
what you're talking about."
And frankly, they were
working in institutions
that have decades of
institutional research data
and systems that use GPA
and things like SAT and ACT,
to pretty good effect.
At least to do what they want them to do.
Nobody was asking us for change.
Like nobody came to us and said,
"Hey, MTC, Can you please give
us a completely different way
of doing our work?"
However, what's happened in the
past couple of years, right?
Well, we've had a global pandemic.
Many institutions have
gotten completely moved away
from standardized testing.
Because of the pandemic,
we've had a lot of kids
who applied to college,
two years ago, with pass fail transcripts
from otherwise traditional high schools.
We've got a lot of kids
who may not have had access
to the remote school,
hybrid school offerings
that their local district
schools were offering them.
And so you've got a lot of folks,
who previously were pretty
content with like the status quo,
suddenly now are kind
of snapped to attention.
Standardized testing is changing.
The concept of credit-based
on C time is changing.
If as many higher ed leaders
do believe that equity
is really critical to college admissions,
understanding that access to education
has been really inequitable
during a pandemic.
All of these things we think
line up in favor of us as a sector.
I mean that like the K12 sector,
moving towards more mastery-based,
competency-based approaches.
In a way that obviously the past two years
have been horrible, at a national level.
For a pandemic, I wouldn't
wish that on anybody,
but it definitely has changed
and accelerated the way
really key stakeholders
are now thinking about
a lot of the stuff we're talking about.
- Yeah.
So let's go to a couple
questions from Facebook.
Rebecca says, "Where can
you find high schools
that are using a mastery curriculum?
Does mastery.org have a list of those?
Where can folks look?"
- We definitely have a list.
Every school that's part
of the MTC membership
is listed publicly on our website.
And I really want to be clear about this.
There are many amazing
mastery-based schools
that aren't part of our network,
and those schools are awesome too.
So I'll give a shout out
to the Big Picture Learning Network,
which is a network of amazing schools
that are really innovating
and really pushing really hard
on thinking about what
schooling looks like,
and how we serve kids.
There's an organization
called the Aurora Institute
that publishes a map and updates.
I think updates it quarterly,
but definitely several times a year.
And they show you
what is the state of
competency-based education,
each of the states.
And it shows you that
there are some states
that are like they're going all in.
They're basically saying,
"We're gonna go personalized,
competency-based
across the entire state."
And it's really interesting
because in a world in which so much
of our educational practices and discourse
have gotten really politicized,
there is no correlation to
the politics of a state,
and its adoption of
competency-based education
or mastery-based education.
It makes for strange bedfellows
in a really good way.
There are some folks who are saying,
"Hey, this is a key driver for equity.
It's about serving communities of kids,
who have been traditionally
under served by our systems.
We need to do better by those kids."
And there's also a model that says,
"We really are focused on business.
We're focused on the 21st century
and being a place where kids can graduate
and get amazing technology
based manufacturing jobs.
And we want to give them
the skills for that."
And what's really interesting is
then you wind up in the same place.
They wind up talking together
about mastery-based learning,
which, I think, is pretty great.
- Yeah. That's great.
And leads actually to Brian
from Facebook's question
of what are the challenges involved
in partnering with public schools?
- Well, it depends on the public schools.
So the challenge and the greatest strength
and liability of our
national education system
is that we have a massively
decentralized system, right?
Sometimes that's awesome.
It gives districts, even
individual schools and districts,
a lot of autonomy to experiment.
I think, we exist largely as a consortium
because there's these
lighthouse districts, right?
Lead by a really
inspirational leader says,
we're gonna do things different.
We're not gonna wait for
permission from our state,
and they need a network.
And so they come and
join us, which is great.
But then there's also
states where the policies
are just not favorable.
If you are trying to
transform your district
and you want to embrace
credit based on proficiency,
rather than on seat
time, it's not gonna help
if the law says, kids have to take X hours
of social studies in order to graduate.
You need someone to give
you permission to do that.
And so those are probably
the biggest challenges.
It's not challenges
specific to public schools,
as public schools.
It's differing rates of adoption
of favorable policy frameworks
in different states and localities.
And again, sometimes
that works in your favor.
Sometimes there'll be
states, Utah, South Carolina.
There's a lot of interest
in Kentucky right now,
where they'll create really
favorable policy frameworks
and provide funding, and then,
it can be off to the races.
- Fantastic.
We have already 30 minutes
in, and at time quickly.
It sounds like the work you're doing,
both really unblocks one of
the big concerns or objections
that folks have, which
is, oh, if we do this,
how are we going to be able
to get students into college
and where those is, which
sounds like one of those pieces.
I'm gonna end on one more question
that came from YouTube,
Nasser Grunono says,
what are all those medals for?
- So they are thank
you, Nasser, out there.
None of them is a victory medal.
And I think that's really important.
And hopefully, on brand
for what I'm talking about.
We're not against, we're an
antis sorting organization.
They're finishers medals
for different races
of different lengths and different types.
And I keep 'em up there
because I think they're
pretty good metaphor
or analogy for grading based on mastery.
If you finish, even if it
takes you a little bit longer,
you still get that.
And if you get a wide
enough array of them,
for different lengths
and different events,
it starts to tell a
story of what you can do.
And so I keep 'em up there
as a kind of a reminder
of what we're trying to do.
Give kids evidence that
even if it takes 'em
a little bit longer to get to proficiency
or mastery in certain areas,
as a long as they got there, it's good.
- Fantastic.
Thanks so much for the work you're doing,
and look forward to seeing more
from the Mastery Transcript Consortium.
Thanks for being with us today.
- Thank you so much.
Spend delight.
- Excellent.
And to all of you,
we actually have another Ed Talk tomorrow
with Nicholas Ferroni, who
is we are going to talk to,
specifically about what it would look like
if we really appreciated teachers.
So stay tuned for that,
and we'll see you tomorrow.